Salam guys I'm going to be reacting to
inshallah me Hassan absolutely
intellectually destroying this ex
Commander General genocidal maniac and
there's something he says at excuse me
at the end that I was like this cannot
this guy cannot he cannot make this
stuff up he cannot like what he says is
literally what they're doing but and we
need to watch but before that brother
sisters this video was sponsored by
Muslim Master inshah to build confidence
and speak brother and sisters confidence
is very important confidence was one of
the things that led me to Islam not my
own confidence but the confidence of Zak
ahed the confidence that he had in his
religion made me realize why is he so
about what he speaking and he made me
listen to him attentively so guys when
it comes to confidence and how to speak
you need this in marriage work
colleagues friends giving da so BR
sisters many diets have also taken this
course inah please check in the link
below let's get straight to the
video asalam Alum brothers and sisters
and dear friends so this is a video of
some kind of a ex comrade General
whatever um genocidal comrad as you can
see and mat H in we're going to watch
this insh and look at some points where
M absolutely Anni him and he mentioned a
very interesting point towards the end
and I was like wow just imagine if
anyone from the other side opposition
side said the same thing let's watch for
ourself in here's the first interaction
where MDI destroys uh this clown I don't
think that any reasonable person can say
well Israel is at fault for Iran twice
firing missiles on all over Israel so
what Israel is doing is defending itself
against Iranian attacks first and
foremost Hamas and Hamas is down but not
out and now dealing uh very latly but
and after a long period of time of
70,000 Israelis being evacuated from
their homes for 11 months but dealing
with hisbah as well and I think that in
the coming days or maybe a little bit
more than that Israel will expand its
defenses to the real destabilizing
factor in the Middle East which is Iran
and to put everything within the netan
context I think it's a bit I think
intellectually lazy and flat there's so
much more to it and it really takes away
agency and responsibility from all of
the other actors that are attack Israel
the Gaza andah and theis and the
Iranians and Iraqis and syrians all of
these they have no agency they have no
responsibility they all are part of the
Netanyahu show I find that a bit hard to
believe and I think it's kind of a lazy
argument to be making all right Med your
response to that well well let's just
deal with the agency issue first a few
things one is a lot of those groups you
mentioned have all said that they're
fighting with Israel is tied to what's
happening in Gaza many of them have
offered the houthis Iran and I said this
few peers last time I came on the show
and you said how can we trust them I
said don't trust them but call their
Bluff they've all said you end the
genocide in Gaza you end the violence in
Gaza you get a ceasefire and we will
stop fighting with is
genoci let me let me let me the genocide
the no the the genocide that your
country the genocide that your country
is being investig can I finish a
sentence the genocide your country being
International court of
justice Jonathan I'll let you respond
after Med finishes his point yeah medy I
barely started but he doesn't want to he
doesn't want people to hear what's going
on all of those groups have said they'll
stop if Israel stops its genocide in
Gaza NBC News reported that Israel
killed nasala because he said I'm only
going to do a deal with you if you do a
ceasefire and Gaza I want to link a
ceasefire and Lebanon with a ceasefire
and Gaza in the Israelis told NBC News
that's why we killed him so we know that
these groups have agency Israel has
agency Jonathan krias wants your viewers
to believe that Israel just blindly you
know Israel was just minding its own
business and Iran attacked it Israel
attacked Iran first in Syria they bombed
an Iranian Consulate in violation of the
laws of international law and
international diplomatic yeah they
killed Iranians in Iran they then bombed
is hania in Teran they bombed the
Iranian capital and then they bummed
Beirut and killed a senior Iranian
General so actually it was Israel that's
been provoking when he talks about s of
destabilization in the region everyone
in the region knows it's Israel that's
destabilizing region it's Israel right
now that's escalating Wars in multiple
countries everyone around the world
knows it's Israel that's the country
that is causing the issues 40 countries
PS 40 countries have just put out a
statement on Saturday saying can Israel
please stop attacking un peacekeepers
blue helmets so please don't give us
lectures on who stabilizing
destabilizing the region and final Point
as for winning um the the Israeli
General who ran the Gaza division Gadi
shamni says Hamas is winning Israel is
losing in a big way those are his words
not my words it's unbelievable I mean
the way they're making it seem as if
Yemen Lebanon uh Gaza Palestinians Iran
everybody's like you know what we are
going to have a fight with Israel
because we're just bored unbelievable
but you see what just happened to him he
got dealt with second Point live here so
I don't think that you're in a position
to be lecturing anybody about what's
really happening in the region I am the
one who is running with my family to
bomb shelters when fires missiles and
when the Iranians fire missiles and when
Hamas fires missiles I am the one who
has family who has been evacuated from
the north I am the one who has close
relatives and friends who were massacred
on October the 7th Don't lecture me
about who is the source of instability I
agree with you that a lot of countries
and a lot of dark people have a problem
with the Jews living in their ancestral
Homeland but that doesn't make it wrong
that we're here we're going to continue
to be here and continue to defend
ourselves despite the likes of you and
despite our enemies and I'll tell you
that our history is so full of people
that wanted to kill Jews and wanted to
to force us out of our homeland but
we're back we're here and we we intend
to continue to stay here despite the
best efforts of Iranians and syrians and
leban and G and others many so I I do
need to respond to that so first of all
as for lecturing you as I say 40
countries put out statement including
many of your own allies including
Hungary one of the most pro-israeli
countries in Europe saying stop
attacking un peacekeepers these are not
dark anti-semite Forces you can't keep
playing an anti-Semitism card and
undermining the very real struggle
against anti-Semitism by using it to
defend a government that is full of some
of the most racist people anti-arab
anti-muslim anti-christian people on the
face of this planet you were spokesman
for a government that contains people
like smotrich and benav open racists
prosecuted for inciting terrorism so we'
got to lectures you should keep your
lectures to yourself and be embarrassed
for the government you served as for you
living in the region the problem is not
you living in the region the problem is
the Army you served and the country you
were spokesman for illegally occupies
other people's lands in the West Bank in
Gaza in the goolan Heights now in
Lebanon again uh you are the country
that is illegally occupying other
people's lands it's not about you living
in your homes it's about you taking
other people's homes it's about Israel
now aiming to Annex Gaza according to
haret this week that Netanyahu no longer
has any interest in Saving the hostages
as he never did and is eyeing annexation
of Gaza to quote the Israeli newspaper
haret and if we're going to talk about
people dying on October the 7th some of
us have done that some of us oppose that
you only oppose attacks on Israel you
support attacks on non- Israelis on
Monday let's say his name let say his
name shab 19 years no no no no you don't
get to interrupt me sorry you do not get
interrupt you have to taking The High
Ground on interruptions on you'll come
back in P will bring you back in I'm
going to finish my point un interrupted
otherwise don't be a hypocrite as well
as someone who represents fascists a
19-year-old young man sh software
engineering
student
sence just wait bring to interrupt
otherwise this conversation will no no
finish
don't
threaten so desperately okay 19 a 19y
old you keep interrupting Jonathan
people can see what a hypocrite you are
19-year-old student Shaban Ahmed
software engineering student at alaza
University Jonathan's military destroyed
his university destroyed his house
displaced him made him homeless five
times over the past year on Monday the
world we all watched him burn to death
thanks to israeli's buming the area
outside the hospital that he was on IV
on a bed in a tent he burned to death
his mother died two other maybe three
other people died I'm not sure how
Jonathan still comes on these shows and
defends that kind of barbarism and open
war crimes I'm not sure how Jonathan
sleeps at night watching people burn to
death thanks to the military that he
served and is now being investigated
both at the international court of
justice and the international criminal
court Jonathan so interesting point so
he is saying that methew you are El not
anything but I'm the one who's running
to bomb shows and doing this and this
Etc that's going my family's going
through this and it's very interesting
he justifies that his family members are
going and running away from these
Rockets but let's go to the base of the
problem because just as you say that the
pal since who were living on those lands
in peace with the Christians and the
Jews Muslims all together they had to
suffer that and the argument you're
using to defend yourself is the same
thing they're saying you started all of
this they're saying you guys started all
of this if you didn't do that to us we
would not retaliate I cannot go and
punch someone in the face and then they
punch me back and then I'm going to hit
them back and then be like and he's
going like yeah but he hit me but why
did I hit you you hit me first I was
chilling here bro I had no problem me
and you were galm you punched me in the
face and tried to take over my and so I
had to uh retaliate anyways let's go to
the next point I indeed served for 24
years in the IDF and I'm a proud Israeli
Zionist and I'm a proud Israeli Patriot
and I also am very proud of my service
including as a spokesperson but also
including as a combat officer in the IDF
I know what I stand for I asking what do
you stand for what what kind of values
do you I for killing civilians like your
military rap DET get to answer Jonathan
did you did you witness
rape did you witness R you will get
I'm not I'm not and I ask what are your
motives and who pays for what you do so
it's very simple answer as I told
Jonathan line of the New York Post I
love this new talking point appears it's
got around the right-wing media and the
pros people I run a company called Zeto
people can check it out z.com it's a
great media organization getting very
good press from The Washington Post and
others there are no foreign investors
they're all American investors I'm an
American you asked the question I know
you can't handle brown people uh you
know being part of the West I'm an
American I'm a Brit I was born in the UK
I'm now an American taxpayer and I'm
very concerned with American taxes going
towards the funding of a genocide in
Gaza going towards the killing of a
19-year-old guy who's in I in a hospital
bed going towards the killing of
children in a school going towards the
killing of 23 people from one family in
Lebanon Monday in Northern Lebanon 23
people bombed by your military two
babies killed Jonathan that is what you
stand for you serve the IDF the Israeli
military which as I say is being
investigated the icg icj and the IC you
serve a military that has been credibly
accused by the United Nations just last
week by Israeli media which showed
videos of mass rape of Palestinian
detainees the the New York Times this
week reported that your military sent
children Palestinian children as human
Shields into booby trap tunnels and
buildings is that what you did Jonathan
can you tell us today did you ever send
a Palestinian child as a human shield
into a tunnel because the New York Times
are saying your military did that the
world food program is saying your
military is starving the people of
Northern Gaza did you starve people when
you were in the military Jonathan what
do you stand for starvation Mass rape
ethnic cleansing genocide every Human
Rights group in the world says your
military is are abuser of Human Rights I
don't know how many human rights you
yourself are personally abused I don't
know if you turned the Blind Eye to rape
on your custody I don't know if you kill
children at Cold BL you know at Point
Blank Range like Israeli snipers did to
people carrying white FL you can tell us
today how many people you've killed or
how many people you talk day listen so
in this point clearly see he's trying to
kind of dehumanize this one of the
things zioners in the Western World
sadly do not like they don't like
educated Muslims who know what they're
talking about cuz it's like oh my gosh
they sound like us because we believe
we're the only moral ones you know with
with The White Man's Burden we're coming
to rescue everybody so when somebody
comes and speaks intellectually and
brings evidences that's why he was
bringing doubt to that what do you stand
for who's funding you where are you
which country are you it's basically
saying you know what what are you it's
us the Civilized World against you but M
shot him down nice and easily next Point
fact that someone wrote it doesn't make
it true all of these things that you
everyone watching the US tell us you
watched people people gun down by the
idea tell I can say I can say
categorically let's just be clear here
on the facts since people are not going
to get the facts because as you've read
my book you know there's a tactic called
Gish Galloping which is what you just
did which is to talk over all the facts
without engaging with them here are the
facts so people can go look up for
themselves Human Rights Watch Amnesty
International the UN Human Rights office
UNICEF unhcr save the children world
food program who Doctors Without Borders
I can keep going refugees International
International Rescue they all Care
International Christian Aid Physicians
for human rights they all say the
Israeli military is to blame for the
casualties for the killing of innocent
people for not giving warnings for
bombing civilian targets and for
starving the people of Northern Gaza
right now save the children say that
Northern Gaza looks like the depths of
Hell the world food program says no food
has been allowed in by your government
and your military since the start of
October and by the way one last point
you mentioned oh maybe 10 soldiers did
this 10 soldiers did that actually
according to the UN this stuff is
systematic and I would ask you you ask
me who my investors are I'll ask you you
were in the Israeli military you proudly
said you were a combatant someone ask
you were you involved in the things the
Israeli military is being accused of by
the international criminal court Chief
prosecutor by human rights groups
intentional killing of civilians
starving of civilians the use of rape
and sexual violence against detainees
using Palestinian children as human
Shields as a New York Times report this
week did you do any of that when you
were in your service Jonathan conri none
of that is correct so just imagine for a
second a Muslim army or for that matter
whoever it is and they've committed
atrocities these Zionist have do you
really think they would have any seat in
anywhere talking or even defending he is
there just imagine the Muslim armies a
general ex Commander whatever for that
matter sitting there and all these
accusations there will be uproar but
this is what we mean when they
dehumanize Muslims don't care he can
come he can casually come there and try
to justify him with it for this reason
there'll be no reasons but you can see
that when it comes to the issue of is
Russia justified in doing what they do
in Ukraine there is not a single topic
our debate I've seen out there about it
but when it comes to Zionism there
the double stands of the western world
two last points you know going after an
enemy aggressively that's what war is
when you're attacked in your home when
your women are slaughtered when babies
are killed when women are raped and when
your civilians are burnt alive and
people are taken hostage that's called a
declaration of war and you fight that
you don't fight it by being nice and you
don't fight it by being gentle you do
fight it according to the laws of armed
conflict and you try to ad her to those
criteria by and large I think that
Israel is succeeding sure there have
been mistakes and sure there suggest
otherwise it's also interesting that
Jonathan responded to your question P by
talking about how and I think I'm
quoting him correctly that when you come
into our homes and you kill our
civilians and you rape our women and you
set us on fire that is a declaration of
war which is ironic because he's just
described everything that Israel has
done in Gaza and the West Bank both in
recent weeks and months and over the
years of occupation so how come it's not
a declaration of war for Palestinians
when Israel does it to the Palestinians
it's only one way traffic only one side
has a right to defend itself right not
the other side okay this was the Crux of
the matter of all of them and these are
all by the way accusations there is
nothing substantial about what he said
said about the intentional killing the
rape children beheading this none of
them must all they were all lies lies
lies lies lies lies lies now the thing
is is he's saying if somebody did this
would you not fight back duh yes I would
not blame you fighting back but you guys
are the ones that actually doing it
there are evidences from your own people
about you doing it from haret yes and
your own government officials saying it
with their own mouths so you saying that
if someone does that to me I have a
right to fight back but in reality you
are the one that's doing it to others
not the one that's doing it to you and
now you are basically using that do you
not look in the mirror and say what a
I am like I'm literally sounding
like a that's the point so you can
do that actually to others but when
those who are really going through those
things that you just mentioned they are
not allowed to resist back and fight
back you cannot make this stuff up and
lastly but not leastly mean puts him in
his face with this last statement Israel
of course I can criticize and I even do
it on my Twitter I've said things about
my Prime
of course I you couldn't even criticize
Mass rape by your fellow solders listen
there hasn't been Mass rap it's such a
it's such a nonsense talking should be
ashamed of your such a nonsense talking
point
won newtimes
Isn isn't saying isn't
Sayan name inquiry last
week call everyone can Google it
Jonathan how we descended into and
that's sister that's not much can be
said inshallah may Allah bless and
preserve you guys brother sisters uh
Matan once again did a fantastic
phenomenal job by exposing these zist
double standard hypoc hypocrit sces
enjoy the video